you
hi everyone is cherry this is video 10
from the beginner to chess master
playlist which is a progressive series
of videos and we're going to have a look
at some chess pawn basics we're going to
have a look at a group of 10 chess terms
I'll be providing the definitions of
each showing what that looks like on
board and in some instances giving some
very basic tips let me remind you of the
importance of doing a video such as this
when it comes time for me to speak on
more advanced topics it's important that
we have a certain vocabulary under our
belt I do not want to have to stop along
the way in those videos and be providing
definitions this will enable me to speak
a bit more freely on those topics so
with that said let me give you a very
quick breakdown of the terms to be
covered in this video it runs as follows
we're going to have a look first well
we're going to have a look at what a
passed pawn is also known as a passer
we're also going to look at what a
protected passed pawn is isolated pawn
doubled pawns hanging pawns backward
pawn candidate passed pawn fixed pawn
pawn island and one more pawn chain so
let's take it right from the top looking
first at what a passed pawn is or a
passer what is that that is a pawn that
no enemy pawn can stop on its way to
queening so by that definition and in
this example there's only one passed
pawn there's only one passer and that is
the pawn on g7 there is no enemy pawn no
white pawn in this case anywhere on the
G file that can be blocking it on its
way to that queening squared g1 nor is
there any enemy pun on these adjacent
files the files next to the G file the F
and H file that can be capturing the
pawn on its way to the g1 square these
tend to be quite valuable having a past
pun they tend to increase in value as
more and more pieces are exchanged off
the board
one reason why a passed pawn is a great
strength it's because a piece of greater
value your opponent's Knight Bishop king
queen or rook will be responsible we'll
have some job now of stopping this pawn
from promoting let's move forward here
looking next at what a protected past
pawn is what does that look like what's
the definition the definition it's a
past punt that has a pawn of the same
color protecting it
so this pawn here is the protected past
pawn he's past and has the protection of
this friendly pawn pawn of the same
color on on g4 this is quite valuable to
have in chess having a protected past
pawn especially so in a simplified
position such as this in a King and pawn
ending if we take stock of this position
looking at it from a material standpoint
we see that each side has a group of
three pawns so material is balanced
however this arrangement of pawns having
this protected past pawn is super
valuable why is that the case well let's
see notice how the White King is able to
approach these two pawns over here and
what does black do in the meantime
unfortunately he has to sit and wait and
that's that's an unfortunate strategy
but what else is there to do if you're
going to try to capture this pawn you
must first capture him but if you're
ever even approaching this pawn this
pawn takes off in Queens so black is
basically paralyzed you stuck here
cannot move cannot go away he has that
job of watching out for this pawn or
watching out so that this pond is not
Queen and what happens in the meantime
is that these two black pawns are
exchanged for just one white pawn the
Queen side smoked over here the ABC and
D files the Queen side of the board the
smoke has cleared there and now the
White King is able to come over towards
the Kings side scoop up the jeep on and
now push right through and get that
Queen so protected past pawn a great
great asset
in the game moving forward looking next
at what an isolated pond is this idea of
isolated ponds or isolated pond
structures and chests is a big one
however I'll just be touching on what
the definition is an isolated pond is a
pond with no ponds of the same color on
the files next to it you don't like that
definition you can just view it as a
pond that's all by himself and can't be
protected by any of your other ponds in
this case here the isolated pond the
only isolated pond is this pawn on d4
just a quick tip regarding isolated
ponds if your opponent if you're playing
on the black side here if your opponent
has an isolated pond when you're able to
identify an isolated pond in the game
look at the squares directly in front of
the isolated pond so again if you're
playing on the black side you're looking
at these squares here just giving you a
general feel the squares directly in
front of an isolated pond tend to be
excellent homes for your pieces your
Knights your bishops etc because they
cannot be chased away that cannot be
attacked by enemy ponds moving forward
looking next at double ponds
what's a doubled pond a double pun is
when you have two ponds of the same
color that are on the same file so by
that definition black has doubled V
ponds these have a tendency to be a
liability in chess double pumps not all
the time
some of the times they can be a
liability I'd like to emphasize the word
sometimes because I think players early
on they learn of doubled pawns and in
their mind they learn that doubled pawns
are bad and in their mind they have this
idea that it just gets the big red X
avoided at all costs but do know that
there are other pieces of criteria that
one needs to be looking into before you
just right off you know having doubled
pawns in your own position there could
be some positives I'll illustrate that
soon enough in this particular case this
is an instance where the double pawns
are very bad they're a great liability
in this case we could even go one step
further these are not just doubled pawns
but in fact double isolated pawns double
isolated pawns are almost always really
really bad there are rare cases where
they can be quite useful but for the
most part doubled isolated pawns are
really really bad in this case here
these two pawns are stopped by just this
one guy here these two pawns here what
we might regard as a healthy pawn
majority on the kingside having two
pawns versus just one black pawn on this
Kings side of the board these guys here
can produce a passed pawn let's see that
in action first both Kings getting
towards the center a little bit and now
what his white do pushes capture capture
and what do we have we know what this is
it's a passed pawn it's a passer and
what does black have to do now well he's
diverted away from this side of the
board he has to hunt down this pawn and
in the meantime white scoops up those
two doubled pawns and will now be
successful pushing through to Queen
let's have a look at another example
regarding doubled pawns just showing
what that looks like
again this here is an instance of
doubled pawns for white double D pawns
and for black doubled B pawns
if I want to just change this position
or I should say add some pieces to the
board and shift these pawns back like so
this is what it's going to look like
this position right here this here isn't
case where it's white to move and
there's some tension between these
bishops right if it's White's turn to
move you capture the bishop if it's
blacks turn to move he could capture
here now if you're a player of the
mentality where I want to avoid doubled
pawns they're no good well as the white
side you may say well I'm gonna I'm
going to capture this bishop I don't
firstly I don't want to allow my
it to capture me and then I have to go
like this and I have doubled pawns and
at the same time you might be saying is
white well now what have I done to black
I've doubled his pawns aha well hang on
there's other pieces of criteria to look
into what did what's not only did you
double his pawns but you could look at
it from the black perspective here you
help the rook out there's other pieces
of criteria that go into pawns being
doubled in fact if it's blacks turn to
move let me make a passing move here on
the black side do you really want to
capture this Bishop white has doubled
pawns but you brought the rook to life
this is now half open file you've helped
white in some sense and maybe there's a
reason that white would want to have
this Square controlled by a pond there's
other pieces of criteria that need to be
considered when it comes time to have
your pawns doubled that could be quite
useful just know that much don't write
them off as being completely bad they're
not completely bad okay let's move
forward here looking next at what
hanging pawns are let's see an example
of what hanging pawns are hanging pawns
are when you have two pawns of the same
color that are together and don't have
any puns of the same color on the files
next to them okay that was a mouthful
here's what it looks like this right
here is an instance of hanging pawns
each of these ponds just just note that
each of these ponds will often be
positioned on half open files as is the
case right here white has these two half
open files the C and D file there could
be some pressure placed on them these
could be a strength they could be a
weakness it will depend on many
different things I just want to give you
a visual of what this looks like
notice there are no other black pawns
here here that could be helping them out
there on their own they could only
protect each other he could advance and
have the support of this guy and vice
versa they're going to likely need the
support of other pieces White will soon
have pressure on them with the rooks
they could be again a strength or
weakness it will depend on the situation
a strengthen that they could advance
maybe change the structure at some point
downside a weakness in that again they
they can't be defended by any other
pawns they're by themselves they'll
require the support they'll need the
support most likely by these other
pieces these other pieces will have to
defend them so that's what the hanging
pawns look like let's move forward here
looking next at what a backward pawn is
a backward pond is a pond that trails
behind a pond of the same color on an
adjacent file so in this particular case
the two backward ponds are this one here
for black the d7 pond and for white the
b4 pond they trail behind this lead pond
right here this would be the lead pond
for white and this would be the lead
pond for black so they're not able to
move they're not able to make one move
and have the support of another pond
this is a deficiency in within a
structure when you have an instance of
one of your pawns being backward and
this is compounded quite often when we
have situations like this I'm just going
to quickly alter this position where I
insert a couple ponds these two here
just popping up these make life all the
more difficult these make life that much
more difficult for the backward ponds
not only can they not advance and have
the support of any of their pawns like
this guy here he cannot advance and have
the support of a black pond not only is
that the case but now there's a white
pond here who's making it even more
difficult for him to try to get here in
advance to get out in front where he
could one day be protected similarly
white cannot advance like this
so easily anymore either because there's
a black pond here clamping down on this
b5 square controlling that be v square
okay
let's move forward looking next at what
a candidate passed pawn is a candidate
pass pawn is the pawn of a pawn majority
that can produce a passed pawn and that
is on a half-open file so in this case
here the candidate pawns notice each
side here has a majority black has this
two-to-one majority on the Kings side of
the board and when it comes time for the
Queen side it is white who has a pawn
majority on majority of two-to-one let
me just clear that out so by that
definition we can identify the candidate
passed pawns they will be this guy here
and this guy here the ones that are on
the half-open files there's a certain
general rule of thumb that we can follow
when we're trying to successfully
advance our pawn majority like this
again upon majority that is able to
produce a pawn majority that can produce
a passed pawn a general rule of thumb we
can follow is that the candidate pond
should lead the way so when you're
playing on the white side here if you're
playing the move
a4 that's an excellent way to to make
progress here you go a4 you go b4 and
then you finally go a5 just making some
dummy moves on the black side that's a
good way to go ahead and successfully
create what is now a passed pawn if you
are to do a different order if you are
to not follow that rule of thumb with
Candida pawns should lead the way
suppose this guy goes first well guess
what this pawn is what he's a bit
backward and notice that previous
example of backward pawn what is black
able to do clampdown in this a
Foursquare how significant is this
really well it's very significant
you play b4 in this position you lose
because of black playing this and this
pond can now not advance successfully
you could create a passed pawn still
like this but you've given black a
passed pawn as well so the short story
here these are the king
it passed ponds and they are the ones
that should be leading the way on your
way to taking your majority and
converting it into a past pun all right
let's move forward here looking at just
three more terms
next one here looking at what a fixed
pond is a fixed pond is a pond that
cannot move due to an enemy pond
blocking it it's a simple definition the
fixed ponds in this position are these
two here basically it's known as a RAM
structure two ponds basically butting
heads here neither one can move the
other each pond here is blocking it and
they're known as fixed punts let's have
a look at another example of fixed ponds
in this position these ponds here are
all fixed we might also consider this as
a closed center when we have when we
identify certain positions in chess
sometimes we identify it as open
position open positions are where there
are several ponds that have been
exchanged other positions are closed
this would be an example of a closed
position one where we have many
instances in other words of fixed ponds
let's have a look at now a pond Island
Pond Island is a group of ponds of one
color on consecutive files with no other
ponds of the same color on any adjacent
files that's a little bit messy of a
definition there let's just see what it
looks like
Pond Islands black has three pond
islands he has a group of two
highlighted right here he has another
pond Island upon island of three and a
pond Island of two in total black has
three Pond Islands whereas white has two
Pond Islands white has a group of three
and white also has a group of four these
ponds here the B for pond C 2 D 2 and E
3 they are a group of four they can be
connected at some
they could be put together and
protecting one another they're
considered Islands in general it's set
in chests that the fewer Pond Islands
you have the better and that's primarily
due to you want your ponds to be able to
watch over one another if when you start
off the game each side has let's say one
Pond Island each one Pond island of
eight that doesn't mean that you don't
ever want to make a pond exchange
because you would break it up into you
would break your Pond Island up into two
there's other pieces of criteria to be
looking into if you don't have a pond
cap sure you're not going to have play
for your rooks but just in general
there's this idea where the fewer the
pond islands you have the better and
let's have a look at just one last
example here looking at what a pond
chain is as a close here a pond chain is
simply a fixed and connected diagonal
formation of ponds we can identify the
fixed ponds in this case we've already
looked at what fixed ponds are and we
have an instance of these guys being
here on a diagonal just providing a
couple more quick terms here this pond
here is regarded the furthest advanced
pond of this diagonal is considered the
head of the pond chain and the guy
that's furthest back is considered the
tail or the base of the pond chain and
looking at it from blacks perspective
this would be the head of the pond chain
looking from blacks perspective in fact
let me just flip the board this would be
the head of the pond chain and this here
would be the tail or the base of the
pond chain this is certainly another
topic to spend some more time on but for
now as mentioned at the start of the
video we're just looking at the
definitions there will be plenty more to
be elaborating on with some of these
terms but for now hopefully this is uh
has been quite useful to you as we move
forward here and as always I hope you
got something out of this video and I
look forward to
shirring video 11 with you so that's all
for now take care bye
you